tricia tine aujourd'hui votre vie est
bouleversée ah oui
bouleversée mais dans le bon sens du
terme je suis enceinte dans quelques
jours bébé sera là et je suis très
contente déjà de pouvoir accueillir un
être fabriqué dans l'amour et avec amour
dans au sein de ma famille vous avez
envie de le faire savoir où
gens qui vous suivent aux gens qui nous
aiment au début j'étais assez réticente
parce que je voulais vraiment vraiment
préserver ma vie privée mon intimité
d'autant plus que bon et en personnage
médiatique donc c'était assez important
de la préserver
et puis après un passage à l'hôpital
parce qu'on m'a dit ce n'est un diabète
gestationnel et de longues discussions
avec la psychologue de l'hôpital de
trinité j'ai compris que j'avais
peut-être mission j'avais peut-être
aussi cette espèce de doha où il fallait
que je puisse parler de la grossesse et
la rendre belle surtout et puis cassé
tous les sujets tabous donc j'ai
commencé au fur et à mesure en parler
sur les réseaux sociaux en parler autour
de moi et j'ai vu effectivement qu'il y
avait certains points qui étaient
méconnus ou d'autres choses qu'on
n'arrivait pas à maîtriser donc voilà
donc c'est sain c'est un grand bonheur
que sa chance dans votre vie de femme
david animatrice dans votre vie
professionnelle parce que vous n'êtes
pas qu'animatrice
ben ça change tout ça change tout parce
qu'en fait on doit se dire qu'on va
accueillir un être on le construit mais
après il faut l'accueillir donc il ya
des décisions qui sont à prendre
il ya aussi des visions c'est à dire
qu'on se projette on se projette dans le
futur on regarde le passé et il ya des
choses qu'on acceptait auparavant qu'on
accepte plus pendant la grossesse
pendant la maternité et après on se dit
ouais en fait il faut plus que je pense
qu'à moi mais je pense aussi à celui ou
à celle que j'attends qu'est ce que ça
change et donc
quotidienne pas mal de choses alors bien
qu'au début j'étais très réservé sur la
question
lorsque j'ai eu mon diabète gestationnel
il a fallu que je puisse m'adapter donc
déjà d'un point de vue nutritionnel
l'alimentation tout revoir tout revoir
mon mode de vie me piquer également je
fais j'ai trois ou quatre piqûres par
jour d'insuline les sorties avec le co
vides il y en avait plus il ya une
restriction enfin il ya plein de choses
mais je crois que ça a surtout ça m'a
permis d'améliorer le propres rapports
que j'ai avec moi même c'est à dire le
rapport que j'ai avec moi même le
rapport qu'on a avec soi donc ça m'a
permis de me reconnecter la grossesse
si voilà c'est une espèce de connexion
avec soin et ce qui en soi c'est
particulier c'était important de se
reconnecter à soi même et je pense que
le moment était venu que je le sois donc
bien qu'on puisse me dit un bain mathieu
à nos fonds tarbes
non finalement il est arrivé quand ils
devaient arriver cet enfant et ça me
permet surtout de devoir d'avoir plus de
visibilité
ça me permet également toutes ses parts
d'ombrés en fait que j'avais en moins ou
que je voyais ben l'âge elles sont
lumineuses elles sont beaucoup plus
rayonnante comme je le disais des choses
qu'on acceptait avant la maternité on ne
les accepte plus après parce que les
rapports avec les autres par exemple ne
serait-ce que les rapports avec les
autres des sols et des relations
toxiques faire des choix également c'est
à dire qu'être dans la frénésie
professionnelle parce qu'on aime parce
qu'on est passionné
à un moment le corps en fait il va dire
stop la réflexion elle va dire stop
on va être plus mesuré dans ses dans ses
projets dans ses envies également et je
crois que c'est un bien mais particulier
quel message
de faire passer aujourd'hui vous êtes la
meilleure version de vous-même croyez en
vous c'est pas banal
tout ce que vous avez en vous bas ce
sont des ressources qui seront
nécessaires aujourd'hui et demain
préserver vous préservez vous préservez
votre famille et surtout profiter
profiter de tout ce que la nature de
tout ce que la vie nous offre même si je
sais que ce n'est pas facile je vous
embrasse
je vous remercie pour votre fidélité
puis je vous remercie aussi de m'avoir
accordé quelques minutes de qualité
quelques minutes de votre temps bisous